hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation titled artificial
intelligence in times of covid19 the
covid net open source initiative this
webinar is part of the clinical
diagnostics and research event and i'm
susie valdez of labrutz and i will be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab roots so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind everyone that
this event is interactive and we
encourage you first to participate by
communicating with other attendees using
our new live chat feature during the
presentation you can find that live chat
located on the right of your screen you
can also participate by submitting as
many questions as you'd like during this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation now if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
simply click on the help desk button
located at the bottom of your screen
within the navigation bar or from the
lobby
finally a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits click on the
continuing education credits tab located
on the abstract window below the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain those credits i now
introduce today's speaker dr alexander
wong the canadi canada research chair in
artificial intelligence and medical
imaging member at the college of the
royal society of canada for complete
biography of our speaker please visit by
the biography tab at the left of your
screen dr wong welcome you may now begin
your presentation
hi i'm alexander wong i'm the canada
research here in the area of artificial
intelligence and medical imaging at the
university of waterloo and today i'm
going to talk about some of our work on
the covanet open ai
initiative
which is our focus on
[Music]
open source ai
during to help with support with
clinical decision support during the
pandemic
and so one of the interesting things i
always like to bring up just as kind of
like a reflection of what has been
happening during the pandemic was this
was actually a slide that i showed from
the johns hopkins dashboard early in the
pandemic when i first gave a talk and at
the time it was already a pandemic of
global scale we had a novel virus with
limited treatment options and no
vaccines at all
then after a few months i gave a talk
again and the situation has gotten an
order of magnitude worse so it's still a
pandemic a global scale that has really
gotten out of control and it still had a
novel virus with limited treatment
options and still no vaccine at that
particular time
and so what is the situation like now
right so as you can see with the number
infection it has increased by another
order of magnitude it still remains a
controlling pandemic of global scale
across the world
and it's still a novel virus with
limited treatment options but now
thankfully we have vaccinations taking
place worldwide and that's kind of state
where we are
and so one of the most important parts
of managing the covet 19 pandemic has
been active screening with rtpcr testing
being one of the most prominent
approaches for testing whether a person
has a covet 19 infection so on the
positive side rt pcr has actually quite
high specificity
however it's actually quite time
consuming to perform a test
taking more than one day before results
and in the past i've seen situations
where it took as much as a week
and not only that it's very a very lab
intensive process and so there's really
short supply in many countries even to
this very day and one of the key things
a lot of people didn't realize is that
there's actually varying level
sensitivity depending on where you swap
via a throat swab a nasal swab so and so
forth and in the more recent study what
they found is that the positive rate
actually goes down as symptom onset and
so what you see on the right is that the
longer somebody has had the covet 19
infection the harder it is to actually
detect it and so rtpcr while being the
gold standard testing approach has
certain limitations
and so more recently there's a much
greater use of antibody or antigen
testing and these the greatest advantage
of these approaches is that they're very
fast so it takes minutes so you can do
at any time to check your results it
also has high specificity but compared
to rt pcr testing
with antibody testing antigen testing
the sensitivity is significantly lower
to the point where earlier in the
pandemic what the national covet
scientific advisory panel in the uk
stated was that currently available
commercial lfia devices do not perform
sufficiently well for individual patient
applications and so while antigen tests
are being much more widely used now and
technology has improved its sensitivity
still remains quite poor compared to a
lot of other techniques
and as a result of the limitations of
these testing approaches
well biggest being that even if you're
able to identify whether this person has
coveted 19 infection you cannot use
these tests to assess the severity level
of that condition uh for treatment
planning triaging uh
you know resource allocation so and so
forth there's been a significant
interest in the use of chest radiography
as a complementary screening approach
and so what does chest radiography allow
for the first thing is rapid triaging
one of the beauty about
chest radiography
is that you can actually get very fast
acquisitions compared to a lot of other
medical imaging modalities and so in
general chest radiography can be done in
parallel to viral testing
as is often the case and in fact uh it's
actually clinical routine in many
situations to for patients with
respiratory complaint to also get an
additional radiography screening using
chest radiography and so this is really
standard procedure the other good thing
about chest radiography is the
availability and accessibility and so in
general compared to other imaging
modalities
it's relatively low cost
low maintenance and it's also readily
available in most clinical sites
both in development countries as well as
developed countries and it's essentially
standard equipment in most healthcare
systems
and not only that chest radiography
comes in portable forms and so it can be
used in a number of different ways that
other modalities cannot be used so for
example chess radiography system so
portable chest x-rays can be performed
in isolation rooms to minimize the risk
of transmission during the transport
system compared to sex systems can
actually be brought to rural areas i've
actually talked to a lot of partner
clinical partners and collaborators
where they actually fly the portable
chest x-ray systems directly to areas
without medical care
and it's also much easier to contaminate
compared to other modalities but last
but not least the most important aspect
of chest radiography
is that it allows for risk
stratification which you cannot do with
rt pcr testing or antigen testing
testing so what that means is that by
looking at the chest x-rays you can
actually get insights into the risk
level and severity of the individual and
so this allows for improved population
management and also facilitates for
individualized care based on risk
and so with all these advantages at the
time
when the pandemic first started we
decided to launch the covet net
initiative
which has now grown into a global deep
learning initiative for covet 19
clinical decision support
one of the unique aspects of our
initiative has been the fact that it is
the first and largest open source open
access initiative for
deep learning for covet 19 clinical
digital support and so you could be able
to access everything from that url there
and not only that we provide
continuously improvements over time with
new releases new updates of both new
models as well as new data to support
the research and clinical community it
really this whole content initiative
started off as a team of two so myself
and my student at the time linda lang
but now it has grown significantly both
in terms of the size of team as well as
in terms of scope of the different tasks
that we cover for covet 19 clinical
decision support
in fact right now it is the most widely
used ai models of its kind for covet 19
in the world and it's used around the
world on all continents and has been
customized for handling different use
cases as well as different demographics
and environments
so what we started off with with uh
detection and wrist stratification of
from chest radiography now covers a much
broader range of clinical division
support tasks across a much wider range
of medical modalities and so we're very
happy to have received global support as
well as coverage to help facilitate
enable and accelerate our particular
initiative
and so a high level overview of the
covet net initiative in a nutshell the
covenant initiative is now comprised of
six main initiatives
the first main initiative is conadex
where we have built the largest most
diverse open access benchmark data sets
related to covet 19 imaging
the next initiative is the covenant cxr
initiative which it was focused on
creating tailored deep learning models
for soros code 2 detection from chest
x-ray images
next we have the covet net s initiative
which is focused on tailored deep
learning models for source code 2
severity assessment from chess x-ray
data
the covet net ct initiative which
focuses on creation of tailored deep
learning models for source code 2
detection
as well as risk stratification for
computed tomography data the covet net
us initiative which is one of our newer
initiatives which is focused on creating
tailored deep learning models as well as
data for sarco 2 detection and wrist
stratification from ultrasound data and
last but not least the covet net ml sis
initiative which is focused on creating
a fully integrated clinical decision
support system for covet 19 that
integrates all of the previous
initiatives together into a clinical
viable platform
and the goal here is to have this
platform available
to facilitate for covet 19 treatment
planning
for
you know wrist stratification
for
detection as well as triaging
and so now i'm going to talk about each
of these individual initiatives in a lot
more detail
and so the very first initiative is has
been the covet x initiative and that
centers around creating the largest open
access data set of its kind
and so here what we're able to do with
the help of a lot of the different uh
partners worldwide was create a data set
consisting of
over 15 000 patient cases
across 51 different countries and the
more important part is that we try to do
in a very diverse manner so this covet x
data set consists of data under
different views so anterior posterior
posterior anterior different imaging
system types be it portable fit or fixed
uh different positions surprising
upright across different gender and age
demographic groups as you can see from
this table and so on and so forth
because what we want to do is create a
data source
for researchers scientists clinicians so
and so forth to leverage and provide
greater learning diversity and
generalization so we could better apply
under different environments and
situations
and so next
is the
uh
how did we actually do this so one of
the key aspects that we're doing has
been how do we actually develop highly
efficient highly accurate and highly
trustworthy ai models in a rapid manner
given the urgency of the pandemic
and so in order for us to do it
especially when we start off with a team
of two is the underlying idea of human
machine collaborative design which is
based on the premise that why don't we
design ai models
via a human driven design and
requirements but with the fine grain
meticulousness
of machine driven exploration
along with machine enabled human driven
auditing and validation so using this
human machine collaborative approach
we're actually treating ai as a
collaborator to work with us to build
better solutions that are more accurate
they're more efficient and last but not
least
highly trustworthy and so by taking this
human in the loop approach it has
enabled us to be able to really create
great models and release them in an open
source manner through our covet net
initiative compared to a fully
handcrafted approach and versus a fully
automated approach a handcrafted
approach simply takes
way too long
and also it's very hard to guarantee for
quality while a fully automated approach
might speed up the process but it
becomes a black box that is very hard to
understand and trust and so by taking a
human in the loop approach it has
allowed us to have a very great balance
between the two
and so how does a human machine collide
design approach work
and so
first we talk from the human aspect so
as the human designer the first thing we
do is we create a design prototype so
that we can scope exactly what the task
and type of data we're actually dealing
with
and how they could possibly
interact with each other
and so first thing a human does is
create a design prototype
the next thing is to then also feed in
the underlying data source that
interacts with the design prototype
last but not least
is to provide the operational
requirements
for the machine to learn from to be able
to produce better improved models that
need those requirements so from a
clinical perspective what's important to
us here is we would like
the machine to explore different options
and finally the optimal model that gives
me the best sensitivity
the best positive predicted value the
best visibility and so on so forth and
so taking our design prototype that
we've created
so a rough scaffolding of what it's
supposed to do the underlying data in
this case medical data as well as the
operational requirements which is it
needs to hit a certain level for
sensitivity for specificity and so and
so forth
all of that is fed into a machine driven
design exploration
platform in this case our generous
synthesis approach where it goes through
a number of different cycles to identify
inspect and figure out what is the best
tailored model for this particular task
and data at hand while meeting the
operational requirements so this is
quite a bit of a paradigm shift from our
usual thought process which is given the
data and the requirements we will go
through it in our process and do it by
hand and so this allows us to do a
number of different things
so the first thing
is that it enables us to create very
lightweight micro architecture and macro
architecture designs in the underlying
ai model in this case a deep neural
network that we would not be able to do
by hand because with a machine it's able
to identify and tweak and construct at a
synapse level at a neuron level from a
neural network perspective but which is
pretty much impossible for a human to do
and by having these very lightweight
microarchitecture and macro architecture
design it really allows us to build
systems that are much more easily
deployable so rather than systems that
rely on the cloud it allows us or very
heavy compute it allows us to create
models that are lightweight enough to
fit on a small embedded system within
the medical device itself so that it
could be portal and used directly in
real time at low cost
and not only that it allows for the
exploration for more optimal
architecture design that has a much
better trade-off than what we can do so
for example in this case this is a
picture of the covet net cxr
architecture and what you can see are a
number of different things one is that
it's comprised largely of depth wise as
well as point-wise convolutions and
these are very lightweight components
which allows for much smaller memory
footprint and real-time performance
not only that it has a very high
architecture diversity
way beyond what a person can design
because
a machine can tailor directly around the
tasks as well as data at hand
it creates selective long range
connectivity to facilitate for better
training of the models as well as
propagation of information uh through
these long-range silos and so the result
is that it allows us to create
significantly lower complexity systems
compared to what's out there but while
being lower complexity has actually
greater sensitivity so in this case
greater than 95
on a particular cohort
but then the question here is great we
use this human machine collab design
approach the first step to build a model
in an automated fashion that's really
catered around the town and it achieves
great numbers from my overall
perspective but are we just happy with
it ready for deployment the answer is no
because there's quite a lot more to it
especially from a clinical perspective
and so what is particularly important
is that when we're releasing clinical
models
what's very important is that we need to
take a very
responsible approach in what we actually
release and deploy
and so to release a model
into the world based purely on just the
accuracy numbers is probably not the
best idea we kind of want to have a much
deeper insight into how it's actually
behaving and making these particular
decisions that is being then channeled
to clinicians
and so a very important step as
part of this human machine collaborative
design approach is not just the design
and building of the model itself but the
design auditing phase
and so every model in the covet nets
initiative
are not only created using this general
approach but they've also been audited
using a explainable ai system for
responsible ai and government
and so how do we actually do this
auditing we use a number of different
explainability approaches
the very first one that we use is called
quantitative explainability
so what is quantitative explainability
in general explainable ai is ai that
kind of gives you an
explanation as to how it's actually
making its decision but in most
explainability approaches they're very
qualitative so what that means is that
they might have a little bit of
highlight here and there to kind of say
this might be a bit more important than
that other aspect but you don't get a
good sense as to the concrete reason is
what exactly is the influence of this
component what actually is the critical
factor that led to decision and what is
the rationale behind it
and so with quantitative explainability
what you can see on the right it
provides the concrete exact insight into
the critical factors to the model
decision so in this particular case what
you see is clearly what's highlighted in
the area is the critical factor that led
to a covet 19 projection and in this
case it's the underlying ground glass
opacities in the lung that led to that
decision but not only that we also
leverage a counterfactual uh driven
explainability approach that gives the
quantitative insights into the impact of
the critical factors against alternative
decisions so what that means is this
counter factual aspect gives you the
justification to this explanation so
what you can see on the right is that by
looking at this particular critical
factor it led it to have a certain
amount of confidence that this is a
covet-19 infection because under other
circumstances where this critical factor
is not being leveraged it would have
thought that it's standard committee
pneumonia
and so this very becomes very important
for us to really understand the
intrinsic behavior in the
decision-making process of all the
models that we trade
and so why is this even important
doesn't it always make the right
decision for the right reason the answer
is no one of the biggest benefits of
leveraging a design auditing approach is
that it helps weed out right decisions
for the wrong reasons early
well before further development as well
as deployment and so here are some
examples of where we are able to
identify
right decisions for the wrong reasons so
on the left are some chest x-ray images
and so in our initial prototyping of our
system what we found using this
quantitative explainability approach was
that it was actually making a lot of
right decisions so we had really great
score very great sensitivity specificity
however it was
getting these great results by never
looking at the actual loans themselves
but by looking at the embedded text to
make a decision which is completely
nonsensical but it's able to do it
because at the end of the day from a
machine learning perspective its
underlying objective is to get a better
result
how it gets it there
is really just based on whether it
doesn't really truly understand the
intrinsic context of the situation and
so by what it found was that by relying
on embedded text i could get great
results so why don't i just use embedded
text and so by identifying this early we
were able to take actionable insights in
terms of removing such texts and load
and behold as soon as we removed that
contact it's able to then identify the
key critical factors in the lungs that
led to the decision of a covet-19
infection or not
on the right is a very similar and
interesting example for
computed tomography so ct scans so what
you see on the right is a initial
prototype of a ct system for identifying
covet 19 where it was again getting
extraordinarily high sensitive
specificity by never looking at the
lungs by never even barely looking at
the body what it did was it always was
able to identify whether or not there
was a covet 19 infection based on the
type of patient bed they were lying on
again this is completely nonsensical but
the system doesn't know any better and
it gains the data around it and so by
half identifying this we were able to
take actionable insights simply by
removing the bed from the cat scans and
load and behold again
it was able to learn to look and focus
on the
disease areas within the lung to make
its decisions and so this allowed us to
create much more trustworthy systems
at the design level
through greater understanding into the
behavior of the decision making process
and so what the other key advantage
of this explainability approach and we
have leveraged this to enable better
systems was it allows for radiologist
validation into the behavior of the
actual covet net models themselves so
our covet net models have not only been
verified
at the design time through design
auditing it's also been verified from a
radiology perspective based on our
radiology collaborators who are able to
use these types of explanations that are
provided to get a deeper insight into
whether or not it's behaving correctly
and so our systems have been validated
by expert radiologists to ensure that
the decision-making behavior as surfaced
by the explainability is consistent with
radiologist interpretation and this also
allows us to validate the quality of the
data as you saw with the earlier cases
there are quality issues like embedded
texts you know and also and there's
other data that has imaging artifacts
and so on so forth by taking this
explainable ai approach it allowed us to
identify all of these individual issues
and either correct for it or exclude
data that doesn't meet the quality
requirements
and so a team of expert radiologists was
able to examine both the radiology
images as well as the actual visual
indicators as indicated by the
explainability as leveraged by the
networks to make decisions to verify
whether or not the systems are behaving
properly and through this iterative
process we're able to directly produce
covet net models that are not only high
in accuracy
height and efficiency
but also is behaving in a way that
matches the radiologist's interpretation
and so
stemming from just even starting off
from the initial covet net cxr
initiative because of the success of the
project we've greatly expanded the
capabilities of this particular
initiative to cover a much broader range
of clinical tests across different
modalities the first one we extended
with covet net s which is for wrist
stratification and so what we did was we
assessed the feasibility of assessing
the lung severity of sars cove to
patients and this is very clinically
important because it really guides
decisions on treatment planning should a
patient use a ventilator should they
undergo certain just oxygen therapy
should they be admitted to icu and so on
so forth it essentially allows them to
decide the next steps on how to best
care for a particular patient and so
what we did was we test the feasibility
by leveraging the scoring system by long
and all which is based around two
different severity indicators one is the
geographic extent of the disease so the
extent of the lung involvement by ground
glass opacity or consolidation as well
as the opacity spent which is the degree
of opacity
in the patient's lungs and what you see
on the right side is different
situations under low severity medium
severity as well as high severity for a
geographic extent as well as for opacity
extent and this is in collaboration with
our clinical partners that still need
broken medicine as well as multifair
medical center
in new york state us and this is the
largest data set of its kind and we've
made this available in the open source
open access manner
and so based on this what we also did
was build a
second system that is based around the
scoring from the rsna lung air space
disease grade so based on three zones
per lung as well as severely based on
the opacity of the six different lung
zones and using this
uh information we were able to
demonstrate the feasibility of deep
learning for co
computer-aided severity assessment for
sarv code 2 severity we have greater
than 92 accuracy and we're continuing to
improve our systems and explore based on
these directions very promising
directions
another area that we focus on has been
beyond just chest x-rays one of our next
steps was uh during the early days of uh
covet 19
cat scans or computer commodity skins
were actually leveraged quite a lot uh
for uh covet 19 infection analysis
while it's being used much less now
direct for direct diagnostic purposes
it's still being leveraged by a lot of
radiologists and clinicians to identify
whether a patient is at the risk of
covet 19 in terms of its overall
severity
at the time in situations where a
patient needs to let's say go for a skin
before an operation or post operation or
for other purposes so essentially during
these uh
doing these uh procedures that are
unrelated to
actual covet 19 using this as a
complementary source to see whether or
not
there is a potential breakthrough a
potential infection so uh actionable
items can be done to take care of it and
so what we did was we built covenant cd
to assess covet 19 infections uh from
cat scans and so what we did was we
trained on over 200 000 cat scan images
or ct scan images which is the largest
and most diverse cohort available in
open access form again all available
through the covet net open access
initiative and what we're able to do was
leverage this exact same process to
automatically create a tailored
ai model for tackling the task of
ct scan detection and risk
stratification to strong success as well
as using the data auditing approaches
you through explainability to really
understand and make sure that the models
are actually identifying the right
things to make a decision so as you can
see here highlighted in red are the
different areas that the model actually
leveraged to make its decision and this
was then clinically validated
by a radiologist to ensure that it is
looking at the right biomarkers in this
case uh it was
next what we did was we then expanded
further into the realm of ultrasound
there's been a lot of a recent trend
around leveraging point of care
ultrasound so pocus systems for uh doing
uh covet 19 assessments and screens so
for detection as well as risk
stratification and so what we did was in
collaboration with the national research
council of canada so nrc we were able to
create a systematic framework for
curating data with over 10 000 point of
care ultrasound images now also open
access open source available to
community to leverage in a very clean
and systematic manner to further advance
their research as well as other clinical
tasks
and not only that based on this data
source what we then did was leverage
this covetx us to then create covetnet
us
which is a tailored deep neural network
for sarf cove 2 detection based on point
of care ultrasound data and so once
again by using this human machine
collaborative approach what we're able
to do is create
models that are highly architectural
heterogeneity
tablet for this specific task
allow us to introduce an
attention condenser network which allows
it to really pay specific attention to
what's important in a very efficient way
and so the result is the underlying cova
net us was able to achieve a area of the
curve rather than
0.98 yet being
353 times fewer parameters so lower
complexity 60 times fewer flops so much
lower computational complexity and
running
14.3 times faster on a raspberry pi
compared to the typical resnet 50. and
so once again this has allowed us to
really create very efficient yet highly
performant models that can integrate
directly into systems and right now
we're actually exploring the integration
of this directly into a ultrasound a
portable ultrasound system to create a
very uh high-performing ai powered uh
ultra cell system for identification of
profit 19 as well as wrist
stratification
next what we did was we expanded it for
more predictive analytics so essentially
for treatment planning so the first
thing we did was we introduced covet net
clinical icu where the underlying goal
is to build tailored deep learning
models for predicting icu admission
which is a very important task in the
clinical workflow to for personalized
care of individuals with covet 19 and so
what we did was we actually leveraged
explainability
to actually improve ai model design
while gaining system level insights and
so how do we do this what we did was
during the actual model creation process
what we did was we audited the model
using the quantitative explainability
that i mentioned earlier to help us
identify at a system level what are the
most important factors that is being
leveraged by this initial ai prototype
in making its decision for predicting
icu admission but not only that we also
identify which particular factors
actually degraded its overall
performance and so by understanding what
are the key factors that led to better
decisions and ones that hindered
decisions what we were able to do was
then exclude the factors that did not
actually improve but actually led to a
degradation in its overall predictive
performance and as a result it allowed
us to create a more streamlined
efficient system compared to before that
actually led to greater predictive
capabilities and accuracy and so
explainability not only allows you to
actually really understand the behavior
system for checks and balances to ensure
that you validate it before you release
in the wild it actually allowed us to
build a system that actually performed
better so that's a very important
secondary goal that or secondary benefit
that quantum explainability allows for
but not only that what we did was beyond
point of explanability we also did trust
quantification so with explainability
it's about understanding why a
ai is making certain decisions
when it comes to trust quantification is
understanding when and where this ai can
produce a trustworthy answer and this is
especially important for garmin deeper
understanding of potential demographic
biases because at the end of the day the
data itself might not be perfect and so
when you have imperfect data and it's
being learned by a ai model in this case
covet net clinical icu you really want
to understand whether or not it makes
equally or
similarly trustworthy decisions across
let's say gender
across age and so on and so forth and so
during this auditing process using trust
quantification we were able to
fortunately identify that the final
covanec clinical icu model had equal
trouble trustworthy prediction for both
males as well as females from a gender
demographic perspective but also had
very
similar levels of trustworthiness from
predictions both for the older
population as well as for the younger
population so by understanding that it's
behaving not only in a uh
very uh
highly accurate way but also with
decisions that are sound we're also able
to identify here that it's actually
making decisions in a relatively fair
way
and so last but not least
we've also
wanted to it's one thing to just build
models and release it in open source
open access and expect people to be able
to use it but when it comes to
clinicians and other clinical scientists
being able to access these models in a
seamless manner for different clinical
studies case studies and so forth is and
as well as for clinical integration is
much more important and so what we did
was
haven't built all these different models
that we're continue to improve over time
we've also started the covet net
clinical decision support
platform initiative where we're building
a full clinical support platform that
integrates directly into existing
clinical health care
i.t platforms to enable case management
improve clinical viewing of uh cozy
cases diagnosis and as well as prognosis
visualization for covet cases full
clinical integration as well as
automatically automatically generate
reports that can
greatly improve the both the consistency
as well as the efficiency of the
clinical disease support process for
covet 19.
and so again this entire software
platform is also open source and
publicly available through the covet net
initiative
and so where do we go from there what's
next as part of the covenant initiative
so we continue to release new and
improved models and data on a regular
basis and a lot of the scientific
community has been leveraging it to
greatly accelerate their research we
continue to advance these generous
strategies for machine driven design
exploration during the human machine
collaboration because we found this
approach to be very effective and we
would like to spread it within the
research committee to help further
research along different areas we're
working with clinical institutes around
the world for feedback and evaluation at
the end of the day the main goal is
beyond just research advancement is to
have systems that can then integrate
into clinical institutes to support our
healthcare workers
we're also incorporating additional
patient metadata such as comorbidities
vital signs blood tests medical history
and so and so forth to have much much
more complete clinical decision support
we've also expanded our covenant
initiative beyond just covet 19. so we
recently released tvnet
which are open source ai models for
attacking the problem
of
tuberculosis screening which is one of
the most deadly if not the most deadly
infectious disease around the world
we've also extended towards cancer net
which is can we leverage our findings
and learnings in the models we build and
transfer this knowledge for
uh cancer diagnosis and prognosis
and as usual we're always looking for
collaborations from around the world so
feel free to contact me at any time and
happy to collaborate
and last but not least i'm going to do
special thanks to our now pretty large
covet net team uh consisting of
researchers and collaborators worldwide
also love to thank the hospitals that
have collaborated and work with us on
our different initiatives because
without clinical partner support none of
this would happen
and also want to thank the different
corporate partners for supporting our
project our initiative all this time
and so thank you very much for listening
and my emails down there if you're
interested in collaboration definitely
let me know we're always expanding this
project to make sure that we
provide as much as we can to the
community at large